au départ de toute l'histoire il y à
cette graine le soja ici dans cette
usine de chalon sur saône en entraide 35
mille tonnes par an pour en faire un
aliment pour le bétail
on va enlever la pellicule de la gamme
ensuite voilà qu'on casse et on va la
chauffer qui on va l'apprécier
donc on va extraire de l'huile on veut
obtenir un résidu solide qu'on appelle
le tourteau de soja s'égrènent viennent
de bourgogne franche comté
c'est la deuxième région productrice en
france avec 80 mille tonnes récoltées
chaque année et uniquement du soja non
ogm
c'est rare puisque 4 % seulement de la
production mondiale n'est pas
génétiquement modifiés les plus gros
producteurs sont les pays d'amérique
au total 350 millions de tonnes de soja
sont récoltés chaque année c'est un
marché en pleine expansion depuis une
quarantaine d'années c'est une plante
qui a des vertus intéressantes dans le
monde dans lequel nous nous engagerons
où l'objectif est de produire sans
utiliser d'intrants chimiques c'est une
magouille mineuse qui fixe la zone
d'aullène et présente beaucoup d'intérêt
puisque la très peu de parasites connu
en tout cas pas sous nos latitudes le
soja est riche aussi d'un point de vue
nutritionnel par la quantité et la
qualité de ces protéines son utilisation
pour l'alimentation animale ne cesse de
croître
le tourteau de soja quel est l'intérêt
1 le taux de protéines d'environ 50%
ensuite le taux de lipides de presque 7
9 % de matière grasse et très peu
d'humidité seulement 2 % d'humidité donc
un excellent stockage et conservation
pour l'adorer animal aujourd'hui ces
propriétés nutritionnelles intéresse
l'industrie agroalimentaire pour
l'alimentation humaine
voici donc ici à verdun sur le doubs la
seule usine en france à s'être lancés
dans cette production
c'est un profil thermomécanique qui va
chauffer la matière l'ex pensée et qui
un peu plus simplement pas permettre
d'obtenir ce type de produits ce qu'on
peut appeler les chocs mais également ce
que te rappeler des miettes ou des
éclats de texturing deux ans de
recherches ont été nécessaires pour
mettre au point le procédé de
fabrication la production a débuté il ya
quelques semaines
milton seulement seront transformés la
première année les débuts sont timides
mais les débouchés prometteurs de plus
en plus d'industriels utilisent des
protéines de soja pour satisfaire des
consommateurs de plats sans viande sans
cesse plus nombreux